I'm on this antidepressant I don't feel
great by the way like I still feel
depressed because I was absolutely
wanting to like end my life when I
started them I probably should be on a
higher dosage if you're going by what
the doctor says but I can't because when
I go on a higher dosage I end up wanting
to piss all through the night and I
can't even live like you know
what I mean like I can't even wake up in
the morning I literally want to have an
orgasm and be able to sleep so I need a
certain amount just to stop myself from
killing everybody
how many of the people out there are
feeling like me probably a lot the level
of trauma I've been through it's uh
crazy I don't even know how I'm here and
then to go through all of that to then
get on the internet and put your videos
out there generally I'm just trying to
entertain people and have a laugh but
the level of vitriol and abuse you're
then subjected to me my own brain's
already telling me I'm a and
criticizing myself constantly so then
you have the waves of abuse coming
through as well you know I never thought
when I was eight years old that this
many people I don't know would tell me
I'm a